hello everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
today we will be discussing about the
best laptops for programming
in the year 2021 let's wait for an ample
amount of time so that few more people
can tune in
by the time please allow me to tell you
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies
so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon
so that you can never miss an update
from us
so i can see a few more people have
tuned in welcome guys
so today we will be discussing about the
best laptops for programming in the year
2021
now without further ado let's quickly
begin with our session
so we have a single point agenda which
is about the best
laptops for programming
so at first we will go through the bias
guide
so bias guide is all about the hardware
specifications that you should be
considering before buying a laptop
so at first we have the ssd and hard
drive
for programming or coding you'll have to
consider
256 gb ssd or solid state drive
you can also consider one terabyte of
hard disk drive or magnetic drive as
well
and speed is basic you'll contribute a
lot of energy filtering through various
records and folders
so once the hard drive is sorted the
next important thing that you might want
to look into
is the ram so for designers ram
resembles water the standard ram limit
concerning general system is around
4 gb that's for designers but
if you are a programmer or a coding
engineer then i would recommend you to
not go
anything less than 8gb so as i stand it
i would prefer to get a laptop with at
least
16 gb but if you are a beginner or kind
of a learner then you can go with 8gb as
well
but if you are a professional i would
highly recommend that
you shouldn't go nothing less than 16gb
of ram
so followed by the ram the next
important thing that you have to
consider is the processor
which is also called as the brain of the
computer or sometimes even referred as
the heart of the computer
now your machine should be eagerly ready
to organize your goals
in such a way that everything looks
normal and nothing is
heavy or overloaded so systems with
intel
i5 or intel i7 with the latest
generation like
9th and 10th would be highly recommended
for programming
and coding so followed by the processor
the next important thing that you might
want to consider
before buying a laptop is about the
options provided by the laptop for
upgradability
just imagine yourself looking for an
extra space
in your ram or looking for an additional
space in your storage
or do some upgrades to your os or
something like that so not all
laptops provide you with an option of
upgradability
just consider macbook if you wanted to
replace your ssd with a hard drive
or if you wanted to just snap in your
hard drive
into your laptop it's near to impossible
you can use an external hard drive
though but if you wanted to
supplant a hard drive it's really
difficult so you need to consider this
aspect as well before buying a laptop
if you are a guy who is looking for
upgrades
so basically what i'm going to say is if
you are
a fan of upgrading your systems then you
should be considering a laptop
which is open for upgrades so this is
about the
bios guide now after the bios guide
let's dive into the next
topic where we will discuss about the
important thing
about how did we select the best laptops
for you
so before starting with listing out the
laptops we basically took some good
research on the
internet so some of the examples of the
websites that
we considered are the techcrunch and
tech radar
and not only that we also spoke with
some it professionals about the laptops
which they personally use for their
daily jobs in their
industry so after going through all the
surveys
all the websites all the reviews from
the idea professionals
we bought up some best laptops list
so that list is also categorized into
three
categories so the first one is about the
high performance oriented laptops
the next one is about the high
portability and finally
the laptops which are the best and the
overall reliability
and performance now let's dive into the
first one which is about the high
performance oriented laptops
so this segment of laptops include the
list of laptops
that have ranked for providing the best
in class performance
so we have a list of laptops in this
particular segment so the first one that
we will be discussing
is the hp spectre x
360. the hp spectre is the one laptop
which is always comprised with some
dazzling gadgets
the hp spectre x360 takes things to
another level
that should mean really something in
addition to a fact that
they always provide the lovely
workstations
now let's look into the hardware
specifications of this particular laptop
if you are considering to buy an hp
spectre x360 laptop then you should be
considering to buy it
with gb to 256
gb sd drive and if you don't want to buy
it with an ssd you can go with
a 512 to 1024 or one terabyte
hard disk drive and followed by the
processor since we're discussing the
laptops for the programming purpose
then i would highly recommend you to buy
the laptops
with a ram size of 16 to 32 gb
and coming into the operating system the
hp
spectre x360 comes with microsoft
windows operating system you can even
change it to linux
it's not difficult to do that now let's
discuss the
pricing of hp spectre x360 laptop
so in india with that specification what
we discussed before
the laptop is available for a whopping
1 lakh 21 000 and 499 rupees
and similarly in the u.s markets the
same laptop
is available for 1499 american dollars
now the next laptop in the list is
the macbook pro 15 inch the 15 inch is
about the 15 inch screen
now let's discuss about this laptop at
the point when you're searching for the
best laptop for programming
particularly in case when you are
creating a software
or an application for mac operating
system
then your best choice would be macbook
pro
macbook pro is always known for its
best in class and smooth performance now
let's discuss the hardware
specifications that you might want to
get in your macbook pro
so as discussed earlier macbooks does
not provide
a support for hdd but you get an
std inside the macbook pro so i would
like to recommend you to get
a ssd of capacity 128 to
256 gb at least and
when it comes to the ram you can even
choose an
8 to 16 gb capacity ram space for your
daily utilities next comes the cpu where
you can choose
the ninth generation intel i9 processor
and finally the operating system so the
macbook pro comes with the latest
mac os catalina the version will be
10.15 now let's discuss the pricing of
macbook so in india the macbook
is available at 1 lakh 54
840 and similarly the same laptop is
available for
2399 american dollars in the united
states of america
the next laptop in the list is the
lenovo ideapad
slim f5i so i personally recommend this
particular laptop
for the developers or the programmers
who are
fans of high speed performance now the
sticky notes are dead
the idea pad 5's webcam privacy shutter
provides a physical barrier between
your world and the creepy hackers and
with a fingerprint reader on the power
button
you can set your ideapad to not even
wake up
unless it detects your fingerprint or
biometric signature
the idea pad 5 comes with a host of
options including a usbc port
for power delivery that replaces the
typical power supply jack or
can be used to plug in into your extra
display
quick charging gets your battery backup
with green in
minutes and with speedy ssd drives
and bountiful memory options this pc is
more than just
an everyday laptop that's the reason we
selected this particular laptop
and i recommended this laptop if you are
a fan of
high speed performance now let's discuss
about the
specifications that you can go with so
the specifications for this particular
laptop
that i would recommend are an ssd of
128 to 256 gb or
and hard disk drive of 512
to 1024 gb or one terabyte
and when we get into the processor i
would like to recommend you that
you should go with a latest generation
intel processor
that would be an eighth one or the tenth
generation processor
and the processor should be an i5 or i7
next the ram should be at least 16 to 32
gb
and lenovo gets your computer with
microsoft windows operating system
now followed by the high speed
performance laptops
we enter into our next segment where we
will discuss about the high portability
options provided by the laptops
so before actually getting into the next
point
we shall finalize the pricing of this
particular laptop
this particular laptop is available at
65 542 rupees in
india and the same laptop is available
for
850 us dollars in american states
now let's get into the next point
so this particular segment is all about
the highly
portable laptops the easily carriable
ones
the ones that you would like to spend
most of the time with
carrying it on your lap carrying it in
your hand
and carrying it all over your office
with ease
such kind of laptops now the first one
in this particular list is
the microsoft surface pro 7 so i would
like to recommend you if you are a fan
of portable laptops
then microsoft surface pro 7 is the
one-stop solution for you now why is
that so
let's discuss about this now the
platinum
microsoft 12.3 inch multi-touch surface
pro 7
combines the portability of a tablet
with the performance of a
laptop thanks to its strong and high-end
10th generation intel core processor
now it connects with usb c port for
charging and
weighs less than 1.7
pounds now this is why i would like to
prefer you this particular laptop
where it is highly portable compared to
its allies
now let's go with the hardware
specifications that you can go with this
particular laptop
so this particular laptop basically
comes with an ssd
so i would like to recommend you to buy
an ssd with
128 to 256 gb capacity
and if you would like to add in your
storage capacity then you can switch
with an external one
and when we come into the cpu
specifications then
you could choose the 8th or 10th
generation intel processors
so basically it comes with a 10 intel
processor
and you can also select the i5 or i7
version of the processor
then the ram size would be 16 to 32 gb
since we're using this for programming
then it basically comes with microsoft
windows operating system as
default since it has from microsoft
now let's discuss about the pricing of
this particular laptop
so in india this particular laptop with
that specification is available at
72 999 rupees
and similarly in american states this
particular laptop is available at
999 american dollars
now let's discuss about the next laptop
in our list
of highly portable laptops so we have
the google
pixel book as the next one in the highly
portable laptops
now why did we choose this let me give
you a briefing on that
so compared to other chromebooks the
google pixel books
overshadows every one of its competitors
thanks to its high horsepower and
versatility
there is no chromebook white like that
and it is one of the best in-class
chromebooks
by providing two-in-one laptop
specifications that you can go with
in the year 2020 and 2021
now let's discuss the hardware
specifications that we get with this
google pixel book so basically this
laptop
comes with an ssd so the capacity would
be 128 to
256 gb and you can also consider getting
an upgraded
ssd with this particular laptop next
you can switch to external hard disk
drive if you refer to
and if you would like to go with an
external hard disk drive then i would
recommend you to buy
a 512 gb to 1024 gb
or one terabyte external hardware for
the computer
and after that you can go with the
processor this particular chromebook or
the google pixel book comes with a
processor that has
intel core i5 or i7
of 10th generation and the ram
specifications would be 8 to 16 gb
you can also go with 32 or 64 gb for
this
and this particular laptop comes with a
different operating system than
microsoft it comes with
chrome operating system now let's
discuss about the pricing of this
particular laptop
so in india this particular laptop is
available at
2 lakh 5 000 rupees and in american
states
this particular laptop is available at
2775
american dollars now the next one in the
list is the asus chromebook
flip so we also recommend asus
chromebook flip as a highly portable
laptop
now let's discuss why now asus has a
strong history of making good
chromebooks
but here the c434 is something special
and it's nearly unique among the other
class of laptops offering
a 14 inch screen laptop with a body of
13 inch model yeah you heard me right
the 14 inch kind of a screen in a 13
inch body
it pulls this trick by minimizing the
bezel size around the screen
there is even a micro sd card slot for
expanded storage
and you might need it as it only comes
with 64 gb
that's not a big difference you can add
on some extra gbs to your laptop
but what matters the most is it is one
of the best
and powerful chromebook that you can
ever get at
this price point now let's discuss about
the hardware specifications of this
particular laptop
or chromebook so this particular laptop
or chromebook basically comes with
64gb of space you can add on some extra
gbs to your laptop by switching into an
ssd or
sd card and if you wanted to switch to
an external
hard disk drive then i would recommend
you to go with a 512
gb or one terabyte one and this
particular chromebook
comes with a powerful cpu that is a
latest generation
that is the 8th or 10th generation intel
processor
which is an i5 and you can also take up
an i7
and the ram size is of 16 to 32 gb
and this particular laptop comes with a
chrome operating system
now the next one is about the pricing
now this particular laptop is available
at 56
754 rupees in india and the same laptop
in america
is available at 770 american dollars
so the next laptop in this particular
segment is the asus
sunscreen go now asus zenscreen go is
considered as a hybrid
signal solution laptop this particular
laptop provides the comfortability and
portability of
a tablet and the performance of a laptop
and this particular screen has a 15.6
inch display
and now let's go ahead and discuss about
the specifications offered in this
particular laptop
so this particular laptop comes with an
ssd
so the capacity is about 120 to 256 gb
and you can also switch to an external
one if you require
or find it necessary and the processor
is
the latest 10th or 8th generation intel
i5 or i7 processor
and the ram is 16 to 32 gb and the asus
zen screen comes with microsoft windows
operating system
now let's discuss the pricing of this
particular laptop
so this particular laptop is available
at 52
500 rupees in india and similarly this
particular laptop is available at
720 american dollars
now the next laptop in our list is the
huawei matebook x
yet another best-in-class laptop from
huawei
the huawei mat book x offers best
performance
more than any of its allies in this
particular segment
at a lowest price now that's stunning
now let's discuss about the hardware
specifications of this particular laptop
the ssd comes with a 256 to 512
gb now you can even increase that if you
want to
you can also switch to external sdd
drives
and it comes with a processor which is a
10th generation i5 or
i7 processor now the ram size is typical
that is 16 to 32 gb
and you can select microsoft windows
10 home as your operating system for
huawei
mate book x now followed by the
specifications
now let's look into the pricing of
huawei
matebook x so this particular laptop in
india is available at 1 lakh 79
999 rupees and in the united states of
america
this particular laptop is available at
2440
american dollars so the next one in the
list
is the xiaomi mi notebook 14.
now let's discuss about this particular
laptop the latest generation intel core
processors provide the necessary
versatility for performance
that should hold your xiaomi mi notebook
14 in a
good state for quite a few years to come
now let's discuss about the xiaomi
notebook 14 specifications
now this particular notebook comes with
an ssd of
256 to 512 gb
and you can go with an external optional
hdd that is of capacity 512
to 1024 gb
and the cpu comes with i5 or i7
10th generation and you can choose the
ram capacity
of 8gb and this particular notebook
comes with microsoft windows home as the
operating system
now the pricing of this particular
laptop in india this particular laptop
is available at 46
999 rupees and this particular laptop
on the other hand is available at 635
american dollars
in the united states of america now we
come into the last segment of our
laptops which is based on
the overall reliability and overall
performance of the laptops
so this particular set of laptops are
preferred by id professionals
for their daily usage and also by some
of the students
who would like to get a lot of
performance extracted
through their computers now the first
one in the list is
the hp elitebook x360 the
hp elitebook series are well known for
their reliability and their age really
good through time
because of the embedded materials they
use
now let's discuss about the hp elitebook
x360 specifications
so this particular laptop can be chosen
as an
ssd driven or an hdd driven laptop
now the std in this particular laptop
will be
128 to 256 gb
and when it comes to hdd you can prefer
to have a 512 gb to 1024 gb
as an hdd in your system now the cpu is
an 8th to 10th generation intel
processor
of i5 or i7 configuration
next the ram that is 16 to 64 gb
and it comes with microsoft windows
operating system
now let's discuss about the pricing of
this particular laptop
now this laptop is available for 1 lakh
69
and ninety rupees in india and two
thousand two hundred and ninety six
dollars in america
now the next laptop available in the
list is the macbook air
13-inch now i would like to recommend
this laptop for the apple
fans now let's discuss about this laptop
best of all the macbook air is still
costly and you can get some
unrivaled performance along 14 hours and
41 minutes of battery life
this combination you'll find from the
very best windows 10 laptops and even
then
you can't compete a head-to-head
competition in performance
when it is against the macbook air
now let's discuss the specifications
that the macbook app
offers now this particular laptop comes
with an
ssd and you can choose 128 gb
to 256 gb you can sometimes even switch
to the external one which comes
with 512-2024 gb and
the cpu will be the ninth generation
intel i9 processor
and the ram size will be 8 to 16 gb and
this particular laptop
comes with mac os cat liner version
10.15 now this particular laptop is
available
at 74 000 rupees in india
and 999 dollars
in the american states the next laptop
in the list is the lenovo
thinkpad e14 now i personally recommend
this particular laptop to you
if you are a hardcore programmer now
let's discuss some points about this
particular laptop
so basically lenovo thinkpads are best
known for the
long battery life durability powerful
performance
sizes and easy to slip into your bag
comfortability they offer
and they are chosen as your best friends
now let's discuss the hardware
specifications of this particular laptop
so this particular laptop is available
in both ssd and
hdd you can choose with 128 to 256 gb
for ssd and 512 to 1024 gb for
hard disk drive and the cpu comes with 8
to 10 gen intel processor that is i5 or
i7
and the ram size will be 16 to 64 gb and
it comes with microsoft windows
operating system now let's discuss the
pricing of this particular laptop
so this laptop is available at 60 19990
rupees in
india and 840 american dollars in the
united states of america
now the last laptop in the list is the
dell xps 13
739 now let's discuss some of the points
on this particular laptop now dell xps
13 offers
some best overall performance in its
class thanks to its 10th generation
intel cpu
and a snappy keyboard and larger touch
pad which makes it perfect
and productive for coding purposes in
very long stretches now let's discuss
about the
hardware specifications of this
particular laptop so this particular
laptop is available in ssd
so you can choose with 128 to 256 gb on
that
and if you would like to go with an
external hard disk drive then you can
choose with
512-2024 gb and it comes with
8th to 10th generation intel processor
that is i5 and i7
and you can go with the ram size that is
16 to 64 gb
and it comes with microsoft windows
operating systems
now let's discuss about the pricing of
this particular laptop
so this laptop is available at 1 lakh 20
750 rupees in india and 1630
american dollars in the united states of
america now with this
we have come to an end of this
particular video if you have any queries
regarding this video then please feel
free to
write them down in the comment section
below and our experts team will be happy
to answer you at the earliest
this is ravi signing off until next time
thank you
you